je crois que j'ai oublié mon texte
je l'avais mémoriser mais
donc je vais essayer d'improviser je
vous demande d'être indulgent avec moi
nous sommes tous guidés par nos
croyances
chacun d'entre nous
mais vous savez
non croyances
conditions de notre façon de penser
notre façon de penser guide nos actions
et nos actions déterminent nos résultats
si la plupart d'entre nous
ont hérité de leur croyances de leur
parents
d'autres si au fil
des expériences
des échecs des réussites qui se sont
forgés quelque chose
mon nom c'est l'âge Boubacar dans ce
cours je suis entrepreneur agricole en
République de Guinée
je suis né un 13 avril 94 ça va étonner
certains
nez le 13 avril 94 je le répète au
effort
et dans un petit village qu'on appelle
titine
dans la préfecture de
je suis quatrième enfant mes premiers
garçons
à partir de là
tout ce que je vous dis ce n'est pas
parce que je m'invite de ma personne
mais vous avez pu comprendre que la vie
m'avait déjà dessiné à quelque chose de
grand parce que vous savez ce que se
représente un premier garçon dans une
famille
africaine de surcroît une famille
guinéenne surtout après une sororité de
donc mes trois premiers les trois
premiers enfants étaient des sœurs défis
ce n'est pas pour dénigrer les femmes
tout à l'heure nous avons vu fadima
passer ici nous voyons bien que les
femmes peuvent bien assurer mais
hélas un garçon représente toujours une
joie pour les parents en Afrique au
point que le jour où de ma naissance
paraît-il que mon père dans un coin de
la maison
s'est retranché et à essuyer et à
écraser quelques larmes
c'est des choses qui me parlent ça m'a
été raconté plus tard par ma mère
j'ai toujours cru en moi
peut-être à cause de tout ce qu'on m'a
raconté sur les conditions de ma
naissance et que je viens de vous
dévoiler au point qu'un jour autour des
précepteur religieux qui nous racontait
l'histoire d'un être parfait un être qui
serait né en Arabie grâce à une religion
a pu fédérer tous les Arabes au point
que à grâce à cette religion il a pu
répondre l'islam un peu partout même en
Afrique
j'étais tellement subjugué par
l'histoire que je me suis levé je dis
Karamoko je te promets que je vais être
cet homme là je le successeur le digne
successeur de cet homme
et qu'a-t-il répondu instafirou là
ce n'est pas possible du tout le
Prophète c'est le Prophète tu ne peux
pas
à part Lui
j'étais très déçu
sincèrement
j'étais tellement déçu
que je me suis retranché il l'a vu il a
senti il a vu qu'il m'avait vexé
mais pour se reprendre il dit je pense
que tu peux être par contre un calife
tu peux être un marabout tu peux être
quelqu'un qui rassemble quelqu'un qui va
sortir les gens de la pauvreté quelqu'un
qui pourra
aider les autres
tout de suite ma voix était tracé c'est
comme si j'étais illuminé de quelque
chose je dis ah d'accord
oui car beaucoup je te promets
inch'Allah la personne que tu as prédit
le sera et ça j'avais juste mais sept
ans
ce qui est temps beaucoup d'eau ont
coulé sur le pont et d'ailleurs je
profite de l'occasion pour prier sur sa
tombe ce carmoco est décédé je lui
souhaite le paradis éternel
et donc j'ai continué de détenir nous
sommes passés à la baie avec mes parents
c'était pas facile notre père a continué
toujours à tétine nous nous sommes
arrivés à la baie j'ai fait juste une
année j'ai été appelé à aller à Dakar
pour de meilleurs études à l'époque la
Guinée était ce qu'elle était
donc on cherchait en Afrique de l'Ouest
à aller quelque part
ce jeune homme là qui avait tant
d'ambition et qui était le premier
garçon d'une famille où il pouvait en ce
moment avoir des études beaucoup plus
qualifiées je débarque à Dakar
un 15 octobre 2001
nouvelle culture
nouvelle langue
problème d'intégration
je ne parlais pas la langue et vous
savez qu'au Sénégal je sais pas si
nabufal j'ai vu FAL donc j'ai tout de
suite j'ai fait le lien avec le Sénégal
mais quand on parle pas le wolof c'est
chaud là-bas parce que la première chose
qu'on fait c'est d'abord de vous
insulter pour voir déjà si vous arrivez
à parler la langue quand on est jeune
mais heureusement très vite je me suis
intégré mais j'avais toujours une arme
c'était toujours parmi les meilleurs de
toujours le responsable de classe de
toujours parmi les premiers et d'être
chef de bande même quand il faisait il
fallait faire le banditisme dans le dans
la classe qui était devant c'était moi
qui fixais les règles
je voulais toujours être devant toujours
le premier toujours devant donc quand je
voyais quelqu'un dans la classe qui
voulait me concurrencer ça commence à
être chaud je te prenais déjà je te
donne déjà ton respect et je continue à
te côtoyer pour comprendre pourquoi tu
veux me dépasser et comment tu arrives à
me dépasser
donc un jour j'étais en train de faire
ma petite prière à mes 13 ans
et je vais vous dire pour moi tout
projet passe à travers une idée une
fondation sans fondation vous ne pouvez
pas aller loin
après avoir fini la prière de astre je
sais pas comment on va l'appeler ici les
Peuls diront à l'encrage je ne sais pas
dans les autres langues
mais après la prière danse
j'ai tendu les mains j'ai dit Dieu
j'ai longtemps prier mais aujourd'hui je
veux te parler de toi à moi et
d'ailleurs jusqu'à présent je le fais
sincèrement pour moi Dieu c'est
quelqu'un qu'on ne voit pas mais qui est
partout donc quand je veux lui parler je
m'enferme dans une chambre et je lui
parle je lui dis ce que je veux donc je
le dis Dieu
j'ai fait une promesse quand j'avais mes
sept ans
à mon calme
je sens quelque chose à moi je voudrais
juste nouer un pacte avec toi le pacte
c'est quoi c'est que rends-moi fort
rends-moi riche
fais de moi quelqu'un qui est toujours
parmi les premiers et je te promets tout
ce que je rencontrais sur ma route je
les aiderai à s'en sortir
c'est la seule chose que je te demande
fais de moi à 18 ans un homme qui est
marié fait donne-moi une excellente
épouse
permets-moi 25 ans d'être milliardaire
je le disais et à l'époque sachez que je
pensais qu'être riche c'était à partir
de 100000 dollars donc je souhaitais
vraiment avoir 100000 dollars dans la
tête c'était ça quand j'avais mes 100000
dollars c'est fini je suis riche
aujourd'hui j'ai compris que c'est très
loin de ça quand on parle de 200
milliards avec je ne sais pas Elon Musk
et Jeff Bezos je me dis que vraiment
100000 c'était du n'importe quoi mais je
disais Dieu aide-moi à voir juste 100000
dollars à mes 25 ans
après à partir de 35 ans sincèrement je
me disais bon je vais faire peut-être de
la politique
et vraiment j'avais rien tracé au-delà
de 55 ans c'était une prière que j'ai
fait quand j'avais 13 ans
aujourd'hui je voulais te voir
et à partir de là les choses se sont
engrangées je pense que la loi de
l'attractivité ce n'est pas totalement
faux parce que tout le temps on est
guidé par ce que l'on pense
j'agis j'agis mesdames mes agissements
je suis surpris de comprendre que le
rêve là a eu un impact sur ma vie et
continue à en avoir à 18 ans je me suis
marié effectivement
aujourd'hui je suis père de trois
enfants à 29 ans
donc je continue donc à 18 ans je me
suis marié je disais à 25 ans je voulais
être milliardaire
pour moi 100000 dollars ça représentait
cela et je peux vous assurer que bien
avant j'avais compté les 100 000 dollars
avec 4 ans exactement donc un an en
avance et à partir de là vous savez
l'homme n'est jamais satisfait dès que
j'ai eu mes premiers son but là j'ai
commencé à dire ah Dieu bon je pense que
on va revoir le truc hein je voudrais
qu'on aille un peu plus loin
[Applaudissements]
mais on abandonne pas donc après cette
prière
appelle tout ce que je vous ai énuméré
je devrais dorénavant respecter ma
promesse qui est d'aider les autres
parce que vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
quand même je suis des chanceux d'être
né dans une famille d'entrepreneurs
aujourd'hui j'ai voulu avec plusieurs
entreprises entre elles produit plus de
720 000 chaque année
avec plus de 300 personnes depuis 2020
elle est là produit de la viande de
volaille du poulet de chair plus de
10000 avec mes sœurs
en essayant tant que possible d'aider
les autres
ce n'est que la partie visible de
l'iceberg il y a d'autres petits détails
que nous ferons et peut-être qu'on ne
dira pas ici mais bref comprenez
qu'aujourd'hui ma motivation
entrepreneuriale c'est de pouvoir aider
les autres parce que Dieu m'a fait
naître avec un 5 là où certains d'autres
sont nés avec un
mais je pense bien que même ceux qui
sont nés avec un un s'ils ont pu
accomplir 3 il va le mieux que moi qui
suis né avec un 5 si j'accomplissais un
7 donc tout dépend de la base et du
résultat obtenu plus tard
réussir requier de l'effort peu importe
d'où l'on vient c'est le thème
normalement que je dois développer mais
que vous dire
sur votre route vous allez rencontrer
plein de personnes qui vont vouloir vous
décourager ils vont vous rappeler
je suis albinos
tu es de quelle technique
tu es venu du village ah nous on est de
la ville toi tu es du village ah ton
père est riche toute façon toi tu es né
avec une cuillère d'or dans la bouche
toi-même tu n'as aucun effort c'est ton
papa qui a l'argent c'est pas toi à
longueur de journée j'entends ce genre
de critique sur les réseaux sociaux je
n'en manque pas de recevoir des
commentaires comme ça qui me font
totalement rire
parce que je sais ce que je vis
je sors très tôt le matin je rentre très
tard le soir pour me battre parce que je
vais vous raconter une chose le plus
difficile ce n'est pas d'arriver premier
mais c'est de se maintenir là-bas qui
est difficile c'est la chose la plus
difficile au monde parce que quand vous
pensez que vous êtes le meilleur vous
trouverez toujours quelqu'un qui est
meilleur que vous
et que vous voudrez attendre
donc pour résumer c'était de vous dire
que peu importe d'où l'on vient peu
importe votre état
si vous vous donnez coréen à une chose
sachez que vous allez progresser la
réussite ce n'est pas forcément
financière
la preuve elle fait encore l'école elle
a dit l'université je sais pas si c'est
le lycée mais il était là devant nous
tous en train de nous donner des leçons
que nous tous nous avons écouté est-ce
que cela forcément c'est une réussite
financière non mais c'est une autre
forme de réussite la réussite est la
plusieurs visages et la plus informe et
ce qu'il faut faire
les conseils dorénavant que moi je
pourrais vous donner
ils Saxe autour ils sont axés autour de
5 points
le premier je vous dirai c'est de croire
en vous
je crois que si je suis arrivé
aujourd'hui à ce stade c'est parce que
j'ai bien cru en moi je n'ai pas écouté
les autres j'étais obstiné par quelque
chose d'être toujours parmi les
meilleurs partout où on devrait parler
bien il faut que je me trouve là-bas
donc c'est de croire en vous
mais également le second point je dirais
c'est c'est de faire de vous faire
accompagner par des personnes positives
je pense que c'est l'un des speech de
de Fatima non de plutôt de Serge
qui a beaucoup attiré mon attention il a
parlé d'un individu ici que je ne peux
pas rappeler le nom mais je pense à un
monsieur Touré il a dit qu'il s'est fait
accompagner de cette personne
pour mon cas ça a été ma famille ça a
été mes parents mais aussi d'autres
personnes que j'ai rencontré sur le tas
et qui ont contribué énormément à me
faire réussir
et à me dire que peut-être ton rêve il
n'est pas si faux que ça il faut le
continuer au-delà de ça je vous dirai de
commencer petit ne voulait pas ne ne
pensez pas vous ne voulez pas aller trop
vite en besoin n'allez pas trop vite en
besoin ne faites pas de très grand pas
ça vous déséquilibre commencer petit à
petit petit à petit on dit que l'oiseau
fait son nid pas à pas pas à pas on
finit finalement pas réussir ce qu'on a
envie de faire quand on est trop pressé
je vous donne juste un exemple une
parenthèse je regarde le temps en même
temps
c'est de vouloir emprunter de l'argent
partout
au départ quand on est entrepreneur on
pense que le problème se résout avec
l'argent plus d'argent ne va pas
résoudre le problème je le dis et les
gens sont choqués mais c'est ça la
vérité quand on veut aller trop vite on
finit par prendre beaucoup d'argent et
c'est de l'argent qu'il faut rembourser
j'ai fait cette expérience avec la
banque
et je pense que ça m'a beaucoup servi
parce que le taux d'intérêt il ne
pardonne pas la banque ce n'est pas ta
famille la banque c'est pas ta famille
donc c'est chaque mois ça tombe et il
faut prendre et enfin qu'est-ce que je
voulais dire c'est de vous former
continuez à vous former vous n'êtes pas
meilleur que les autres
donc qui n'avance pas recul parce qu'en
réalité pourquoi cette adage est
important qui n'avance pas recul parce
que si vous n'avancez pas les autres eux
ils avancent
donc finalement c'est vous qui reculez
donc formez-vous continuez à vous former
tout le temps tout le temps de telle
sorte que vraiment ça dure on finit
jamais d'apprendre et toutes ces belles
personnes qui sont passées devant moi
leur parcours m'ont inspiré c'est
pourquoi des événements comme ça sont
importants c'est des moments où on
échange on comprend ce que vit l'autre
et à partir de là on peut tracer sa
route et pour finir que dire à part vous
remercier et vous dire finir par ça ayez
confiance en vous je suis persuadé
qu'ensemble nous allons réaliser quelque
chose de grand je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]